9. sınıf tayfa. Selamlar. Daha 9. sınıf
tayfa demeyelim de artık yavaş yavaş 10.
sınıf tayfa diyeceğiz. Ey güzel
arkadaşım 9. sınıf matematiğin artık
geldik son teması olan 7. temaya verden
olasılığa deyip son temayı da işleyip
artık 9. sınıf matematiğine son noktayı
beraber koyacağız ve önünde bir yaz
tatili var. O yaz tatilinin sonucunda da
10. sınıfa doğru koşar adımlarla
gideceksin. Yalnız bu yaz tatilinde de
9'dan 10'a geçenler için de marif model
kamplarımız olacak. Takipte kalırsam
bunların her birinin duyurusunu
yapacağız. Beraber bu yaz döneminde hem
tatilimizi yapalım hem de önümüzdeki
yıla 10. sınıfa da sağlam bir şekilde
beraber hazırlanalım diyoruz. Artık son
bir tema için 7. Tema elimize kalemi,
önümüze notumuzu aldıysak hiç korkma.
Biliyorum olasılık lafı duydum. Biraz
can sıkar ama basit mantıklarla en temel
mantıkla başlayacağız. Bu derste biraz
şöyle bir sözel kısımlarını
inceleyeceğiz. Sonra adım adım
olasılığın derinliklerine ineceğiz. O
halde diyelim mi beraber gönder gelsin
be hocam. Şimdi ey güzel arkadaşım
olasılığa giriş yapmadan önce olasılığı
tanımlamak için önce bazı durumlardan,
bazı kavramlardan bahsedeceğim. Önce
olaydan beyler bayanlar bir olay mı var?
Gelelim mi? Takılalım mı şurada ne var?
Durum nedir? Dediğimizde hani olay
lafını kullanıyorsun ya cümle
içerisinde. Olay dediğim şey matematikte
bir deney sonucunda gerçekleşmesini
istediğimiz veya beklediğimiz durumların
kümesidir. Bu tanımı daha iyi anlamak
için bilmemiz gereken temel kavramlar
var. İşte olay kavramını daha iyi idrak
etmek için önce bir deneyden
bahsedeceğim sana. Deney nedir hocam?
deney. Deney sonuçları önceden
belirlenemeyen ancak gerçekleşebilecek
tüm sonuçları bilinen eylemlere deney
denir. Örneğin bir sayı kübünün
atılması, bir havanın havaya atılması.
Bunların her biri bir deneydir. Bir eee
sayı daha doğrusu bir parayı havaya
attığın zaman bunun sonucunda neler
çıkabilir? Ne çıktılar olabilir? Hocam
bir yazı gelme ihtimali vardır. Bir de
tura gelme ihtimali vardır. Bu
yaptığımız işlem parayı hava havaya atma
işlemine biz ne diyormuşuz? Deney
diyormuşuz. Ya da torbadan top çekmek,
torbadan bilyeler çekmek. Bunların her
birini deney olarak adlandıracağız.
Çıktıysa bu deneylerin sonucuna
diyeceğiz. Bir deneyin gerçekleşebilecek
her bir olası sonucuna denir. Mesela sen
demin o parayı havaya attın. havaya
attığında oluşabilecek durumlar,
sonuçlar nelerdir? Parayı havaya atıp
baktığımızda yani elimize alıp
baktığımızda düştüğünde yazı gelecektir
ya da tura gelecektir. İşte biz buna
deneyin sonucunda gerçekleşebilecek
çıktılara diyoruz. Yani çıktı demek
sonuç demektir. Bir sayı küpü atma
deneğinde ya da bir zar atma deneyi de
olabilir. Zarı attığın zaman hangi
ihtimaller var zarın yüzeyinde ön
yüzeyine gelebilecek? 1 gelir, 2 gelir,
3 gelir, 4 gelir, 5 gelir, 6 gelebilir.
İşte bunların her birini ne olarak
adlandıracakmışız? Çıktı olarak
adlandıracakmışız. Evet, sıkıcıdır
bunlar ama bu kavramları bilmeden de
soru çözmek olmaz. Hemen devam ettim.
Örnek uzaya geldim. Örnek uzay ne? Bir
deneyde elde edebilecek tüm çıktıların,
olası tüm durumların oluşturduğu küme
kümeye eee örnek uzay. Yani aslında buna
hani evrensel küme olarak tanımladığımız
küme bütün kümeleri içeren küme ya bu
ona benzer. Yani sen bir zar atıyorsun.
Olabilecek tüm çıktılar nelerdir? 1'den
6'ya kadar olan tüm zar numaralarıdır.
İşte tüm çıktıların toplam hepsine biz
örnek uzay olarak adlandıracağız. Ve onu
da ne ile gösterecekmişiz? E sembolü ile
gösterecekmişiz. Mesela bu örnek uzayda
bir zarı ya da bir sayı küpüne
attığımızda gelebilecek olan örnek uzay
elemanları 1 2 3 4 5 6dır. Ya bunların
her biri birer örnek uzaydır. Bunun
eleman sayısını se ile gösteririz. O
halde eleman sayısı kaça eşittir dersin
bu örnek için 6'ya eşittir dersin. Olay
nedir hocam? Artık olayı
tanımlayabiliriz sanki. Şimdi şimdi
geldik olaya. Örnek uzayın herhangi bir
alt kümesine Bir dakika. Örnek uzayın.
Yani bütün ihtimallerin herhangi bir
tane alt kümesine biz ne diyecekmişiz?
Olay diyecekmişiz. Mesela eee örneğin
bir sayı küpü atma deneyinde. Bir sayı
attığımız zaman sayı küpü yani bir zar
atmaktan bahsediyorum. Bir zar attığım
zaman 1'den 6'ya kadar ihtimaller
gelebilir. A olayı olarak tanımladığım
olay sayı küpünün tek sayı gelmesi
attığımda. Tek sayı gelebilecek olaylar
nelerdir? Bak olasılığı nedir demiyorum.
Olayları soruyorum. Biz sayı küpünü
attığım zaman tek sayı gelebilecek olan
olaylar 1 gelebilir, 3 gelebilir, 5
gelebilir. O zaman bu olay A olayı
olarak tanımladıysam 1 3 5'tir
elemanları. B olayını sayı küpünün asal
sayı gelmesi olarak tanımladıysam 1'den
6'ya kadar olan numaralandırılan
sayılardan hangileri asaldır? 2, 3 ve 5
asaldır. O halde B olayının elemanları
nelerdir? 2'dir, 3'tür, 5'tir dersim. C
olayının sayı küpünün 6 gelmesi olarak
tanımladıysam 1'den 6'ya kadar bir tane
6 olduğu için bu kümenin elemanı 6'dır
ve C olayının
eleman sayısı bir tanedir ve o elemanın
6 elemanı olarak adlandırsın. Yani
kısacası biz olayı örnek uzayın alt
kümesi olarak tanımlayacağız. Tamam mı?
Peki mesela bir zar daha doğrusu bir
parayı havaya attığın zaman tüm örnek
uzay nedir deseydim? yazı ve turadır
derdin. Peki bunun alt kümeleri nelerdir
dersem yazı olabilir, tura olabilir
değil mi? Bunlar birer her biri birer
alt uzay olarak yani kısacası bizim için
bir olay olarak tanımlayacağız. Peki
olay çeşitleri ile devam edelim. Hocam
basit olay, bileşik olay ve kesin eee ve
bir de imkansız olayımız var. Basit
olayı tanımladığımızda sadece tek bir
sonuçtan oluşan olaydır. Eğer sayı
küpünün 6 gelmesi eleman sayısı bir
tanedir. Tek bir olaydan oluşuyorsa biz
buna basit olay diyoruz. Bileşik olayı
ise birden fazla sonuçtan oluşan
olaydır. Sayı küpünün tek sayı gelmesi.
1 tek sayıdır. 3 tek sayıdır. 5 tek
sayıdır. Bak birden fazla sonuçtan
oluşuyorsa biz bunu bileşik olay olarak
tanımlayacağız. Kesin olay ise
gerçekleşme olasılığı %100 olan olaya
biz kesin olay olarak adlandırırız.
Mesela bir sayı küpünde sayıları
attığımızda 7'den küçük gelme olayını
sorsaydım bir dakika ya bir zar
attığında ya da bir sayı küpü attığında
zaten 1'den 6'ya kadardır. 7'den küçük
gelme olayı kesin olaydır. Ne atarsam
atayım oyun yüzüne 7'den küçük bir sayı
düşecektir. O zaman biz bu olayı nasıl
olay olarak adlandırırsın? Kesin olay
olarak adlandırsın. Bir de imkansız olay
var. Gerçekleşme olasılığı 0 olan
olaydır. Boş kümeye aittir. Yani boş
kümeye eşittir. Boş küme sembolüyü ya bu
şekilde gösterirsin ya da böyle bir 0
koyar üstüne bir çizgik atarsam bu boş
küme anlamı taşıyacaktır. Mesela sayı
küpünün 7 gelmesi. E bir zarın ya da bir
sayı küpünün 7 gelmesi olayı olabilir
mi? Hayır. 1'den 6'ya kadar numaralardan
oluşur. 7 hiçbir zaman gelemez. O zaman
biz bu olaya nasıl olay deriz? İmkansız
olay zaten. Kelime anlamlarından da bunu
çıkartabiliyorsun. Peki adım adım
örneklere şöyle bir yavaştan başlayalım.
Bize bir örnek uzay verilmiş. Örneğin
burada aile bireylerinin akşam yemeğinde
sırasıyla hamburger, köfte, pizza, kuru
fasulye arasından birini seçmesi. Bu bir
olay mıdır? Evet bu bir olaydır. Yemekte
etli bir yemeğin tercih edilmesi bir
olay olarak verilmiş bize. Burada örnek
uzay. Bunların her biri örnek uzay.
Hamburger, köfte, pizza, kuru fasulye.
Bunlar her biri örnek uzay. Tüm yani
benim elemanlarım. Peki ben bunların
içerisinden bir alt küme seçiyorum. Etli
bir yemeğin tercih edilmesi bunun için
bir nedir? Olaydır. Olay mıdır? Evet. Bu
bir olay olarak tarif edilir. Açıklamada
da şöyle diyebiliriz. Etli yiyecekler
kümesi, hamburger, köfte. Bunlar örnek
uzayın birer alt kümesidir olarak
açıklarsın. Mesela sıradaki örneğe
baktığımızda 4 haneli bir şifrenin her
hanesine 1'den 4'e kadar rakamların
gelmesi. 4 haneli bir şifrenin her bir
gelmesi. Bir örnek uzay olarak verilmiş
bize. Peki olay olarak tanımlanan şey
şifrenin sadece çift rakamlardan
oluşması. Buranın çift rakam olması,
buranın çift rakam olması, buranın çift
rakam olması, buranın çift rakam olması.
1'den 4'e kadar 2 ya da 4 gelecek.
Buraya 2 ya da 4. Buraya 2 ya da 4.
Buraya 2 ya da 4. Buraya 2 ya da 4. Bu
bir artık bizim için olay belirtir mi?
Evet. Çünkü örnek uzayın bir alt
kümesidir. Olay belirtecek midir? Evet
hocam. Olay belirtecektir. Şifrenin
sadece çift rakamlardan 0 ya da 0 değil
hocam 1'den 4'e kadar çift rakamlarımız
ne? 2 ve 4. 2 ya da 4'ten oluşması. 2 ya
da 4 bizim için nedir? Örnek uzayın
örnek uzayın örnek uzayın bir alt
kümesidir diyebiliriz. açıklamaya da.
Peki sıradaki örneğimize baktığımızda
bir çalma listesindeki 100 şarkının
sırayla çalınması bize örnek uzayı
olarak verilmiş. İçinden olay şu
seçilmiş. Çalan şarkının pop türünden ve
3 dakikadan kısa olması. Bu bir olay
mıdır? Evet. Bu 100 şarkının içinde
bazısı pop müziktüktür, bazısı rock,
bazısı cızdır, bazısı metaldir, bazısı
arabstir. Bilmiyorum sen hangisini
seversin. Ben tam böyle böyle rock
seveceğim bir adamımdır ama bilmiyorum.
Pop da dinleriz yani. Bizim olay olarak
tanımlanan bu türlerin içerisinden pop
türünden ve 3 dakikadan kısa olması.
Evet bu saydığım örnek uzay kümesinin
içerisinden bir eleman olduğunu fark
ediyorum. O zaman bu bir alt uzay
olduğundan dolayı buna biz ne diyeceğiz?
olay olarak tanımlayacağız. Peki bu bir
olay açıklamasını nasıl diyebiliriz?
Çalan şarkının pop dakikadan kısa
olması, kısa olması elimizdeki örnek
uzayın bir alt kümesidir. Örnek uzayın
örnek uzayın bir alt kümesidir. Bir alt
kümesidir. O halde biz bunu ne olarak
tanımlarız? Olay olarak tanımlarız.
Sanki işin mantığını anladın gibi. Şu
örneğe de bakalım ve geçelim. Bir
şehirde gelecek 7 günün hava
durumlarının neler olabilir? Güneşli,
yağmurlu, karlı gibi tahmin edilmesi.
Havanın en az 5 günün yağmurlu olması.
Havanın 5 gününün en az 5 gününün
yağmurlu olması bir dakika bir olay
mıdır? Yağmurlu olabilir, güneşli
olabilir, karlı olabilir, dolu olabilir.
Bunların içerisinden bir alt olay mı
saydım sana? Bir alt uzay mı saydım?
Evet. Bunların içerisinden bir alt küme
söylemiş oldum aslında. O zaman biz bunu
ne olarak tarif edeceğiz? Olay olarak
tarif edeceğiz. Evet, olaydır. Neden?
Ben nelerin içerisinden saydım? Alt
uzaylar içerisinden saydım. Çünkü
yağmurlu olması yağmurlu olması bir alt
kümedir. Kimin? Benim örnek uzayımın bir
alt kümesidir. Örnek uzayımın alt
kümesinden bahsediyorsam biz buna olay
olarak bahsediyoruz. Tamam mıdır? Geldim
ikinci örneğime. Aşağıdaki tabloda boş
bırakılan yerleri bu doldurunuz demiş.
Olay olup olmadığından bahsetmiş bize.
Metrobüs durağında sıranı bekle.
Metrobüs durağında sıranı bekle. Ya bu
bir olay değil ki. Bu bir cümle. Hem de
nasıl bir cümle biliyor musun? Emir
cümlesi. Emir. Şuraya açıklamaya emir
cümlesi diyelim. Emir cümlesi. Olay
mıdır türü? Türü nedir? Türü olay
değildir diyelim. Olay değildir. O halde
ne derim ben? Emir cümlelerinden olay
çıkmaz. Bu yaz tatile çıkacak mısın? Ne
yapıyorum? soru soruyorum. Bu da bir
olay değildir. Olay değildir hocam. Alt
kümelerini sayamam. Burada bir örnek
uzay yoktur. E burada örnek uzay yoksa
olay oluşturamam. O halde deriz ki soru
cümlelerinden soru cümlelerinden ne
olmaz? Olay olmaz de sanki yavaş yavaş
bu örnek uzay nedir? Örnek uzayın
içerisinden alt kümeler seçebiliyorsam
buna olay dendiğini herhalde kavradım.
Geldim şimdi sıradaki durumları
incelemeye. Gel önce bir okuyalım
beraber. Aşağıda 1 ve 1den çok olay
içeren durumlar verilmiştir. İnceleyiniz
şimdi bir olay içeren durumlara bakalım.
Bir sayı küpünün 6 gelmesi. Evet tek bir
olay içeriyor. Sepetten rastgele bir
meyve seçip elma çıkması. Elma çıkması
tek bir olaydır. Bir madeni para atılıp
tura gelmesi, yazı ya da turadan tura
gelmesi tek bir olaydır. Bir kartı seçip
kırmızı renk kart seçiyorsun tek bir
renk geliyor. Bu da bir olaydır. 1den
çok olay ise 1den çok durum demektir.
İki sayı küpü birlikte atılıp toplamının
7 gelmesi, bak toplamının 7 gelmesi 1den
çok olay içerir. 4e 3 gelebilir, 5'e 2
gelebilir. Birden çok ihtimalden
bahsediyorsam birden çok olay içermesi
demektir. Hafta haftadan rastgele gün
seçip hafta sonu olması. Hafta sonu
günleri neler? Pazar ve cumartesi. Bak
birden çok olaydır. Bir madeni para iki
kez atılıp her ikisinde de tura gelmesi.
Tura tura olarak gelmesi birden çok
olaydır. Biz buna birden çok olay içeren
durumlar olarak bahsedeceğiz. Eğer tek
bir olay içeriyorsa biz bu olaya basit
olay, birden çok olay içeriyorsa ise
bileşik olay olarak adlandıracağız. Bak
bu örnekleri okuduğumuzda kafanda daha
çok canlanacaktır. Sabah erkenden uyanıp
kahvaltı yapmak tek bir olay.
Uyanıyorsun, kahvaltı yapıyorsun. Ancak
sabah erkenden uyanıp spor yaparak güne
başl. Bak şimdi spor yaparak güne
başlıyorsun. Sabah erkenden uyanıyorsun.
Üstüne de spor yaparak güne başlıyorsun.
birden çok olay içeriyor. Kitap okuyarak
vakit geçirmek. Bak vakit geçirmek.
Kitap okuyarak vakit geçiriyorsun. Tek
bir olay var. Kütüphaneye gidiyorum. Hem
araştırma yapıyorsun hem de kitap
okuyorsun. Hem kitap okuma var hem de
araştırma yapmak var. O zaman birden çok
olay o var. Bahçede dinlenmek tek bir
olay. Bahçeyi sulayıp çiçekleri budalmak
birden çok fazla olay içerdiği için biz
buna bileşik olay diyoruz. Tek bir durum
varsa basit olay. Birden çok durum varsa
bileşik olay. Müzik dinlemek nasıl bir
olaydır? Basit olaydır. Markete gidip
alışveriş yapıp eve dönmek. Markete
gidiyorsun, alışveriş yapıyorsun, eve
dönüyorsun. Bunların her biri birden çok
olay içerdiğinden dolayı bileşik olay
olarak örneklendirebiliriz. Hadi gel
buradaki 3üncü örneğimizde hangilerin
bileşik yani bir olay, hangilerin basit
olay, birden fazla olay içerenlere biz
bileşik, tek bir olay içerenlere de
basit olay diyorduk. Hangileri basit,
hangileri bileşik? Bunları bulmaya
çalışacağız. Bir olay içerenlere tik
işareti koyuyorum. E diğerlerine de
koymayalım o zaman. Akşam yemeği
pişirmek. Akşam yemeği pişirmek hocam
tek bir olaydır. O zaman tek bir olaya
tiket koydum. Arkadaşlarla buluşuyorsun
sonra da sinemaya gidiyorsun. Aa bir
dakika birden çok olay içeren o zaman
biz buna tik işareti koyalım. Bu
birileşik olaydır. Ne diyorduk? Birden
çok olay içeriyorsa bileşik olay olarak
adlandırıyoruz. Bir olay varsa basit
olay olarak adlandırıyoruz. Televizyon
izlemek tek bir başını tek bir eylem
var. O zaman bir olaydır. Ödev yapmak
tek bir eylem durumu söz konusuysa basit
olay. Doğal olarak bir olay içeriyor.
Basit olaydır. Müzik dinleyerek resim
yapmak. E birden fazla eylem var.
Bileşik olaydır. Parka yürüyüşe çıkmak.
Tek parka yürüyüşe çıkıyorsun. Bir
olaydır. Mutfağı temizleyip akşam yemeği
programı izlemek. İki işi birden
yapıyorsun. Bileşik olaydır. Ödevini
bitirip ödevini bitiriyorsun.
Televizyonu izliyorsun. Yine nasıl bir
olay içerecektir bizim için? bileşik
olay içerecektir. Birden çok eylem varsa
bileşik olay, tek bir eylemin
içerisindeysen basit olay olarak
adlandıracağız.
4. sorumuza baktığımızda aşağıdaki
tabloda verilen olaylara ait çıktılarla
ilgili alanlara yazınız. Olayın alt
çıktılarını eee doğru ve tam şekilde
doldurunuz demiş. Yani olayın şimdi
çıktı neydi? Bir verilen bize örnek
uzaydaki tüm olası durumlar bizim için
çıktıydı. Olayın çıktıları ise istenen
olaydaki tüm durumları yazacağız. Olay
şu. Bir sayı kübünün atılması deneğinde
çift sayı gelmesi. Şimdi çift sayı
gelmesi neler çift sayıdır? 1'den 6'ya
kadardaki çift sayıların benim için bu
olaya ait çıktılardır. O zaman bu
çıktılar 2 olur, 4 olur. Bir de kim
olur? 6 olur. Bir madeni paranın
atılması deneyinde yazı gelmesi çıktısı
nedir? E y'dir. Bir tek yazı gelme
kısmıdır. Sadece kırmızı ve mavi
bilyelerin olduğu bir torbadan çekilen
bilyenin kırmızı gelmesi. K'yi ben ne
olarak gösterebilirim burada? Bu olayın
çıktısı olarak gösterebilirim. Bir sayı
küpünün birlikte atılması deneyinde
toplamlarının 7 gelmesi. Şimdi
toplamların 7 gelmesi için 1'e 6 atarım
7 yapar. 2'ye 5 atarım 7 yapar. 3'e 4
atarım 7 yapar. Bunların her biri bizim
için birer çıktıdır. 4e 3 atarım 7
yapar. 5'e 2 atarım 7 yapar. Bir de
tekrardan 4e 3 atarım ne yapar? 7 yapar.
Bunların her biri benim için birer
çıktıdır. Hocam sanki bir tane de eksik
yazdık. Kimi yazmayı unuttuk? 6'ya 1 mi
var? 1i 6'yı yazdıysak 6'ya 1'i de
almamız lazım. Eksik bırakmadık değil
mi? 4'ü 3'ü iki kez yazdık. O zaman şunu
silelim artık şuradan. Şimdi oldu mu
çıktılarım? Şimdi oldu. Haftanın
günlerinden birinin rastgele seçimi
deneyinde seçilen günün C harfi ile
başlaması. Şimdi o zaman C harfiyile
başlıyorsa benim çıktılarım neler
olabilir? Cuma, e, C ile başlıyor.
Cumartesi, e, başka var mı C ile
başlayan? Başka yok. O zaman benim
çıktım burada iki tanedir dersin,
çıkarsın selamı. Gelirsin 5. soruya.
Şimdi 5. soruda ne sormuş? Şöyle
baktığımızda aşağıdaki soruları bize
cevaplayınız demiş. Tabloda verilen dört
deneyin bir veya birden çok olaydan
oluşup oluşmadığını belirtiniz demiş.
Baktım deneydeki olay sayısı 1 mi birden
çok mu? Yani basit olay mı bileşik olay
mı? Tespitinizi, durumunun neden basit
veya bileşik olduğunu açıklayarak
yazınız demiş. Hadi bakalım. Bir
öğrencinin sınav notunun 85 veya daha
yüksek olması. Şimdi deneydeki olay
sayısı 85 veya daha yüksek olması ne
demek? 85 olabilir, 86 olabilir, 87
olabilir. Birden fazla eylem mi
içeriyor? Evet hocam. Birden fazla durum
söz konusu. O zaman buradaki olay sayısı
85'ten kaça kadardır? 100'e kadardır.
Peki buradaki olay basit olay mıdır?
Bileşik olay mıdır? Biz bunu ne olarak
tarif edeceğiz artık? Bileşik olay
olarak tarif etmiş olarak tarif
edeceğiz. Neden? Birden fazla durum söz
konusu. Çünkü geldim ikinci örneğe. Bir
süpermarkette alınan iki ürünün de son
kullanma tarihinin geçmemiş olması.
Şimdi burada bir süpermarkette alınan
iki ürünle son kullanma tarihinin
geçmemiş olmasında kaç tane elimizde
olay var? Aslında iki tane olay var.
Birden fazla olduğu için deney sayısı
2'dir. İki tane ürün var. Açıklamaya ne
derim o zaman? Biz ne diyebiliriz biz
burada? Bileşik olay olarak
adlandırabiliriz.
Bir kişinin sosyal medya paylaşımı
yapması. E tek bir kişi sosyal medya
paylaşımı yapıyorsa tek bir olay vardır.
Tek bir durum vardır. Açıklama tek durum
olduğundan dolayı ben bunu nasıl olarak
olay olarak tanımlarım? Basit olay
olarak tanımlarım. Bir torbada mavi veya
yeşil bilye çekmesi. Mavi çekebilirim,
yeşil bilye çekebilirim. İki tane durum
vardır. O zaman birden fazla durum varsa
biz buna bileşik olay olarak
adlandırılırız. Ve bunların da hangi
olay türleri olduğunu da belirlemiş
olduk dedim. Ve geldim hemen bir sonraki
sayfadaki 6. soruma. Şimdi 6. soruda da
aşağıdaki tabloda verilen her bir
olasılık deneyi için o deneyde
gerçekleşebilecek tüm olası durumlarının
oluşturduğu örnek uzayın eleman sayısını
açıklayarak yazınız demiş. Bir
öğrencinin sınav notunun 1 ile 100
dahili arasında bir tam sayı gelme
deneyine bakacağız. Şimdi bir öğrencinin
1'den 100'e kadar alabileceği puanlar 1
2 nokta nokta kaça kadardır? 100'e
kadardır. O zaman 1'den 100'e kadar 100
tane tam sayı vardır. Örnek uzay dediğim
tüm elemanlar toplamıydı. 1'den 100'e
kadar 100 tane tam sayı olduğuna göre o
zaman buradaki örnek uzayımın eleman
sayısı 100 tanedir dersin. Olay basit.
Bir madeni paranın üç kez arka arkaya
atılma deneyim. Şimdi 1 2 3 3 kez
atacağım. Birincisini attın yazı gelecek
ya tura. İki ihtimal var. İkincisini
atacağım yazı gelecek ya tura. İki
ihtimal var. Üçüncüsünü atacağım yazı
gelecek ya tura. E iki ihtimal var. E
bunlar hepsi art arda üç kez atıyorsam
aynı anda istiyorum demektir. Bağlı
olayları çarpıyorduk. Çarptığımızda 8
farklı durum olduğunu görürsün. O halde
buradaki örnek uzayın eleman sayısına ne
dersin bu sefer? 8 tanedir dersin. Kolay
anlaşıldı mı? Bir şehrin hava durumunun
güneşli, yağmurlu ya da karlı olması iki
gün üst üste tahmin edilmediğini iki gün
üst üste tahmin edeceğim. Ya güneşli
yağmurlu ya da karlı gelecek. Kaç
ihtimali var? 3 ihtimal var. 1inci gün 3
ihtimal. İkinci gün yine 3 ihtimal
vardı. E 3 k 3'ten 9. O halde burada
oluşabilecek tüm ihtimaller benim için
örnek uzayı oluşturuyor. O halde örnek
uzayının eleman sayısına 9 tanedir
dersin. Tamam mı? Bir markette 10 farklı
meyve suyu arasından iki farklı meyve
suyunun sırasına dikkat etmeden
seçilmesi deneyinde örnek uzay nedir? 10
taneden iki tane mi meyve suyu
seçecektiniz? seçim varsa kombinasyon
vardır. Onun o ikili kombinasyonunu
inceliyorum hemen. 10 x 9/ 2 x 1 diye
çözüyorduk. 10'la 2'yi sadeleştirdim. 5
9 kere 5'ten 45. Demek ki burada
oluşacak tüm olaylar 45 adettir. Bütün
olayların tamamına da örnek uzay
diyorduk biz burada. O halde örnek
uzayımın eleman sayısı benim burada 45
tanedir. Daha doğrusu tüm çıktıların
tamamına biz ne diyorduk? Örnek uzay.
Türkiye'nin 7 coğrafi bölgesinden
rastgele birinin seçilmesi. 7 taneden
bir tane seçiyor. Yli birlik
kombinasyonu. O halde buradaki örnek
uzayımın eleman sayısı kaç adet
olacaktır? 7 adet olacaktır. Olay inan
bu kadar basit. Sen sen şimdi örnek
uzayı anlıyorsun. Olayı anlayacaksın ki
bu durumlardan sonraki derste neye bir
bağlama çekeceğiz? Artık olasılığa doğru
bir bağlama çekeceğiz. Şimdi 7. soruda
aşağıda verilen olayları dikkatlice
inceleyiniz. Her bir olayın gerçekleşme
koşulunu sağlayan eleman sayısını SA
olarak gösterdik ve bunların eleman
sayılarını kutucuklara yazınız demiş.
İki basamaklı [homurdanır] doğal
sayılarda rastgele birinin seçilme
deneyinde 10'dan 99'a kadar hepsi değil
mi? 10 ve 99 dahil olmak üzere bunlar
benim aslında örnek uzayım. Bunlar
içinden bir tane olay seçiyorum. Demiş
ki seçilen sayının 90'dan büyük ve tek
sayı olması. Hem 90'dan büyük olması hem
de tek sayı olmasını istiyorsun. Neler
olabilir? 91 93 95 97 bir de 99. Kaç
tane eleman var? 5 tane. O halde ben bu
olaya A olayı dediysem bu A olayının
eleman sayısı kaç adettir? 5 adettir
dersin. Olay bundan ibaret. 1'den 10'a
kadar sayılardan birinin seçiminde asal
sayı gelmesi. Şimdi asal sayı gelmesi
bir olay. 1'den 10'a kadar sayım var. Bu
örnek uzayı. Bunların içindeki asal
sayılar artık bu olayı gerçekleştiriyor.
A olayı demişim. A olayının elemanları 1
ile 10 arasındaki asal sayılar 2, 5 ve
7'dir. O halde A olayının eleman sayısı
kaç tanedir? 4 tanedir dersin. 8 erkek
ve 7 kız öğrenciden oluşan bir gruptan
bir erkek ve bir kız olacak şekilde iki
kişilik bir komite seçilecek. İki
kişilik komite seçiyor. Kombinasyon
devreye girecek. 8 erkekten bir tane
erkek istiyorsun. 7 tane kızdan bir tane
kız istiyorsun. Bunlar o zaman kaç
ihtimal oluşur? 8 kere 8'in birlik
kombinasyonu 8. 7'nin birli kombinasyonu
7. 7 kere 8 56. O zaman buradaki oluşan
a olayı olarak tanımlarsam bu a olayını
56 adet şekilde gerçekleşir dersin. A
olayının eleman sayısı da 56'dır deriz.
Tamam mı?
2 adet hilesiz sayı küpünün atılması
deneyinde üst yüze gelen sayıların
çarpımının 12 olması. Şimdi 2 adet zar
atacağım. Üst yüze gelen sayıların
çarpımı 12 olacak. 1 atsam 1 en fazla 6
gelir. Diğeri 12 yapmaz. 2 atarsam ne
gelmesi lazım diğerinin? 6 12 yaptı.
Başka 3 atarsam 4 gelir 12 yapar. 4
atarsam 3 gelir yine 12 yapar çarpımları
başka 5ile gelmez zaten. 6 atarsam 2'yi
atarım diğerinden yine çarpımları 12. O
halde bu olaya A olayı dersem A olayının
elemanları bunlardır. Eleman sayısı kaç
tanedir dersem o halde eleman sayısı 4
tanedirdi. Tamam mıdır? Geldim 8.
soruya. Bir torbada 1'den 15'e kadar
numaralandırılmış 15 özdeş top
bulunmaktadır. Bu topların renkleri
aşağıdaki gibi gruplandırılmış. Maviler
1'den 5'e kadar, kırmızılar 6'dan 10'a
kadar, sarılar 11'den 15'e kadarmış. Bu
torbadan aynı anda 3 tane top çekiyoruz.
Çekilen üç topun hepsinin farklı renkte
olması biçiminde bir A olayı
gerçekleşiyor. Buna göre bu A olayının
hangisi bir alt kümesidir? Topların
numaraları. Bakalım neler olabilir. 1 6
11. Önemli olan bunların her birinin
farklı rengi temsil etmesi. 1. Maviyi
temsil ediyor. 6 kırmızıyı temsil
ediyor. 11 sarıyı. Bak 3 tane top. Üçü
de farklı bir renk. O zaman A olayının
bir alt kümesidir bu. Topların renkleri
mavi, kırmızı, sarı. Evet. Üç top. 3 de
farklı renk olacak. O zaman bu A
olayının bir alt kümesi olacaktır.
Topların numaraları demiş burada 5 10 15
olabilir demiş. 5 olursa mavi olur. 10
olursa kırmızı olur. 15 olursa dikkat et
sarı olur. Üçün rengi yine farklı oldu.
O zaman 3üncü durum da A olayının bir
alt kümesidir. Hangileri bu durumu
tanımlar? 1, 2 ve 3 bu durumu tanımlamış
olur. A olayının bir alt kümesi örneği
olarak gösteririz ve geliriz bu
dersimizin son sorusu olan 9. soruya. Bu
arada olasılık konusunu toplamda
yaklaşık 4 derste bitireceğim. İlk kısım
biraz sıkıcı, sözel kısımların olduğu
yerdir. Bir sonraki derslerde işte
sıklıktan, görelik, sıklıktan, deneysel
olasılıktan yavaş yavaş artık olasılığa
girdiğim yer olacak. Ama 3üncü ve 4 ders
artık gerçek anlamda o olasılık soruları
çözdüğümüz kısım olacak. Geldim dersimin
sonusuna. İki basamaklı doğal sayıların
her bir özdeş bir karta yazılıp bir
torbaya atılıyor. Bu torbadan aynı anda
3 tane kart çekiliyor. A olayı bak
neymiş. A olayı çekilen üç karttan en az
ikisinin numarasının tek sayı olması.
Şimdi 3 tane kart çekiyorsun. En az
ikisinin tek sayı olması. İkisi tek o
zaman biri çift olabilir. En az ikisi
tek demek üçünün de tek olabileceği
ihtimali vardır. O zaman bu a olayı ya
bu şekilde gerçekleşecek ya bu şekilde
gerçekleşecek. Şimdi bakalım öncülere. A
olayının alt kümelerinden biri tam
olarak iki tek ve bir çift kart
seçilmelidir. Evet, gerçekten iki tane
tek, bir tane çift seçilince A olayının
bir alt kümesi oluşuyor mu? Oluşuyor. A
olayının gerçekleştiği durumlardan bir
tanesinde 11 15 59 olabilir. Hayır ya 11
15 59. Bir dakika, bir dakika. 11 tek
sayı. 15 tek sayı. 59 tek sayı. Hocam 3ü
de tek sayı oldu. Olamaz deme sakın.
Neden? Her üçünün de her üçünün de her
üçünün de tek sayı olması en az ikisinin
tek sayı olduğu anlamına gelmez mi? O
zaman bu A olayının bir alt kümesi
olarak tanımlanır. Ya bu şekilde
gerçekleşecek ya da bu şekilde
gerçekleşecek. O zaman ikinci öncül de
doğru oldu. 3üncü öncüle geldiğimde
çekilen üç kartın üçünde çift sayı olma
durumu ya 3'ün çift sayı olma durumu
benim istediğim o a olayı değil. A olayı
en az ikisi çift şey en az ikisi tekti.
En az ikisi tek demek. İki tek bir çift
ya da 3'ün de tek olması demektir. O
zaman 3. durum A olayının bir alt kümesi
değildir. Doğru cevabım 1 ve 2'dir
deriz. Çakarsın bu soruya selamı. Artık
geliriz bir sonraki kısımda sıklık,
göreli sıklık, deneysel olasılık, klasik
olasılık diyeceğimiz yer yani olasılığın
artık tanımını vereceğimiz kısımlara
adım adım geçiş yapacağız. Bu dersi
burada bitirelim. 3 ders daha yapıp
bununla bunun dışına 3 ders daha yapıp
olasılığa da noktayı koyup 9un
matematiğinde bitirmiş olacağız. Benden
şimdilik bu kadar. Videoyu beğenip yorum
yapmayı unutmayalım. Sonraki videolarda
görüşmek üzere. Her zaman söylüyorum
sizleri çok seviyorum. Hoşça kalın.
Hoşça kalın.
[müzik]
>> [müzik]
>> H
[müzik]